[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLITCH: How you appear really
defines a lot how you act.
in a fursuit, the way I can
perform and the way can act
wouldn't really work
not in a fursuit.
You can't just run around
and act like a fool
if you're not a
giant dog, you know?
This con is my
personal favorite.
I mean, if I would put a
favorite, it would be this con.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
In the '70s or
'80s, furry meetups
started happening at
science fiction conventions.
But it's definitely
exploded since the internet,
The internet is like the primary
social forum for furries.
The textbook definition
is "an animal
with human characteristics".
But personally, I like
to think of it as more
just a bunch of monster people.
It's really hard to
pin down one thing,
because there's so many
different types of people.
A lot of people assume that
every furry has a fursuit,
but I would say that not
even half have fursuits.
[CHEERING]
VERIDIAN LUPINE: To me,
fursona is some people
will take a combination
of whatever animals
that they feel
closest to, feel favor
to, or just general
like-- try and combine
the best traits of that and then
the best traits of themselves
into something new,
something great.
The best of both worlds
created into one.
I pretty much had to make my
family because my family was
broken apart early on in life.
So I made my own.
And I found it easier
through the fandom.
GLITCH: Yeah, I felt
like when I found
this place that I came home.
That's kind of
what it felt like,
because it was just
this big culture that
was so loving and open.
When I meet someone
who's not a furry,
I definitely don't tell
them that I am a furry.
I feel like there's a
bad conception of us
that kind of creates a
wall between our culture
and mainstream culture.
Hey, sex sells, you know?
That's what people
want to hear so that's
what they're gonna hear.
VERIDIAN LUPINE:
Yeah, sometimes I
feel like I do gotta hide
this, because there's
a lot of stigma behind it.
A lot of us will try and say,
oh, we're not all like that.
No, we're not this.
We're not like that.
No, not a lot of us are like
that, but something we do
gotta accept is that
does exist there.
Yeah it seems really weird
to people-- grown men,
people older than me in
those weirdass suits.
Really, it is just for fun.
You know, it's
just for community.
It's just for connections.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GLITCH: What does your family
think about the whole furry
thing?
POISON: [LAUGHS] I've
been weird since,
like, I don't know how long.
They got used to me
being gay, and then they
got used to me doing this and
doing that and now the furries.
And so they're not even fazed.
It is a lot of work
to walk in a suit.
It is.
You need somebody to
help you move around.
She tells me when
there's kids around,
because I can't see
anywhere down here.
When I need water, she
puts it in there somehow.
She figures it out.
She's always-- she's
got my back. [GIGGLES]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JANA HILLSTROM: I was introduced
to the furry community
through my son, who's a furry.
I, myself, am a
husky-- a white husky.
This is my first convention,
and it's fantastic.
It's wonderful.
And the people, I can say I've
never met a furry I don't love.
Our family's very open.
We talk.
We listen.
We laugh.
We make fun of.
We do all that stuff.
That's what life
is-- to understand.
And at least if you
don't understand,
then find out why
you don't understand.
Be part of it.
VERIDIAN LUPINE: Sometimes
I feel-- go to these cons,
they can just kind of escape
their real world for a few days
and just enjoy just that
animalistic closeness, just
that otherworldly nature,
just another person,
another identity--
something else completely,
just for a little while.
And as long as those
people remember
that they gotta come back,
then they're going to be fine.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JACOB HURWITZ-GOODMAN: To
see another niche culture,
check out what really
happens at a snuggle party.
ADRIANA BORDEA: When
I really hug someone,
I feel very vulnerable.
So I'm intrigued to
see what it's going
to be like to hug strangers.
JACOB HURWITZ-GOODMAN:
If you want
to see "Seeker" episodes
three days early,
then checkout Vessel.
Vessel allows you to watch
exclusive, early access videos
before the rest of the internet.
Click the link in
the description
for your free 30-day trial.
If you want to see more
stories from around the world,
be sure to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]